ten pumps from the fire service are at
the sea and further pumps are being
installed at throughout the day and
evening by doing this we have lowered
the water level by half a meter and
further palms are on route to help lower
the level of the dam a more stress that
the structural integrity of the dam wall
is still at a critical level and there
is still a substantial threat to life
should the dam wall fail so I'll play is
that we would ask for residents to
continue to heed police advice and stay
away from Whaley Bridge and we can give
further updates as soon as we have them
now we know that this is being very
distressful for the residents of Whaley
Bridge and I would like to say a big
thank you to them because they have been
really supportive we've had officers
visit every location and the majority
have been absolutely fantastic taken
that advice have been directed to safety
so anyone who have been displaced but
not attended the evacuation rendezvous
point which is at Chapel high school can
still do that we would still urge people
to do that a tender school it's at Long
Lane chapel on the fritz
at heidi further to this we know that
there's some real concern from the
residents who have left their address
and this can concern medication as well
so urge that anyone who does not have
their prescription medicine available as
a result of the evacuation make sure
that they get it quickly and easily by
calling the NHS on 1 1 1 as this has
been progressed we know that it was
critical to get people out of that area
in doing so we know people have the
residents have left and belongings
behind that they would need essential
belongings and also there's some real
concern around animal welfare
now we have been it's always been in our
mindset to be able to inform the public
how long this is going to take it's
really difficult and until we get all
the pumps in place to be able to make
that accurate assessment we're not going
to know but this is a very difficult
decision that we've made we've made
collectively we need to consider the
situation of the residents and we will
be put in plans in place for residents
to return to their addresses for a very
short time very controlled to pick up
really vital things that they need along
with the animal welfare that they can
tend to but this is very controlled I
must stress that because this is very
critical and it is still life at risk
local offices and partners have held a
residence meeting inform them directly
because we believe that it's and right
that the resident should hear that
directly from from us I must stress that
any resident who does wish to enter
Whaley breach our advice that they do so
at their own risk and that the risk to
life remains high in the area